[Music]
aerodynamics basically is the study of
fluid flow around objects NASA is not in
the business of designing soccer balls
or any balls for that matter are testing
them what we do use sports balls here
especially in our lab and so our
educational purposes you found that it's
very easy to get young kids interested
in our field by showing something they
can relate to what we have here is a
wind tunnel which is basically a chamber
through which air flows when it comes to
soccer ball what we're looking at is the
flight of the ball through the air
there's a very thin film or layer that
forms near the ball surface and it's a
behavior of that layer which we call a
boundary layer which is critical to the
performance of the ball that's why the
aerodynamics go it's the structure of
the outside of the material the
roughness that's what determines the
aerodynamics of the ball
snuggling is when the ball flies
erratically severe or it may change your
actions as its flying through the air
what's been done to the brazuca is that
by using these pounds with with fingers
on it the seam length has been increased
compared to the ball in 2010 what are we
looking at with the smoke patterns is
where does that smoke leave the ball at
what point along the surface and when
that position of that separation
location changes suddenly then that is
the speed at which the ball will knuckle
the most I think the basic message for
the players is that I think you'll see
less of this knuckling effect they'll
find that it behaves more like the
traditional ball and I believe they'll
be happier
[Music]